hi I'm Matt Welch with Nick Gillespie
we're here on ask of libertarian 2012
day to mark the publication in paperback
of the Declaration of Independence our
next question comes from Andrew Ian
dodge via Facebook
who's calling himself libertarian for US
Senate Maine which is uh new to me
what do libertarians and scare quotes
think about the gay marriage issue in
light of the vote in North Carolina
Proposition 8 going to the Supreme Court
and the legalization of gay marriage
initiative on the ballot in November in
May I believe in marriage equality I
think that individuals regardless of
sexual orientation should be free to
marry and divorce with impunity
throughout this vast you know experiment
and liberty by the same token one of the
things that's always interesting and the
tension in a decentralized libertarian
political structure is at what point do
you say this particular write or process
is not central to somebody's you know
kind of natural or inalienable rights
so is gay marriage the equivalent of
racial segregation which nobody now says
should be allowed at any level or free
speech in in the public arena or in some
kind of anything that is kind of
legitimated by government I tend to come
down very heavily in favor of more
freedom at all levels but I also
recognize that's a tension with the idea
that different strokes for different
folks and different types of
governmental units for different types
of people as well there's a common
libertarian argument that you hear Ron
Paul among others gave it was like well
let's just get government out of
business of marriage which is a fine
idea and I'd like to hear people express
the same enthusiasm about heterosexual
marriage in the meantime as long as
governments are recognizing marriage I
just can't understand or kind of cotton
the idea of discriminating against one
class of citizens this is ask a
libertarian 2012 we're going to be right
back
you